meet the real cultists
that's the focus of tonight's angle you
have to hand it to the anti-trump
resistance they've tried a lot of
different things to stop Donald Trump
well during the campaign the chattering
classes at various times called him a
racist xenophobe he was a misogynist he
was stupid a fraud in business oh he
wasn't as well-read as the other
candidates oh he also didn't play nice
in the sandbox remember with his fellow
Republicans he was brash boorish and an
egomaniac not fit for the presidency and
now after this IG report came out
yesterday we know that burrowed inside
the FBI were agents by day an activist
by night who were working on an
insurance policy to stop Trump from
winning the presidency and then when
that didn't work
fired FBI director Jim Comey leaked his
notes to a pal who in turn leaked him to
the press all to trigger the appointment
of special counsel Robert Muller on that
bogus Russia collusion theory and now
more than a year and seventeen million
dollars later while the special counsels
approval numbers have gone down and
president Trump's have gone up hey the
economy is soaring and he's unleashed
the possibility of a denuclearized for
Korean Peninsula and of course Trump is
enforcing our immigration laws after
years of neglect wages are going up
unemployment is way down and as a result
Americans are more confident about their
future yay
so now the Trump resistance they got to
try something new it's not a good place
for any party to end up with a cult-like
situation as it relates to to a
president it is devolved into a cute
little leading a cult so cold it's fair
to you yeah I think the Republican Party
is is headed that way I think it I think
cult is a very strong but a very good
word in this case Obama called us bitter
clingers and
hillarie called us a basket of
deplorable x' in an agent and commis FBI
used less ambiguous language check out
this nugget from the IG report this was
how an agent described Trump voters the
day after the 2016 election Trump
supporters are all poor to middle-class
uneducated lazy PRS that think he will
magically grant them jobs for doing
nothing they probably didn't watch the
debates aren't fully educated on his
policies and are stupidly wrapped up in
his unmerited enthusiasm nice well look
Donald Trump isn't perfect none of us
are but more Americans are seeing that
his new and often unconventional
approaches to governance are paying off
and they're seeing past the press is
constant sniping and criticism and
they're recognizing that through it all
Trump has focused on making life better
safer more prosperous for the American
people
that's not cultish it's common sense the
closest thing to a cult that we've seen
in politics over the past decade is the
cult of Obama who can forget these gems
you know you are the the equivalent of a
rock star in politics the feeling most
people get when they hear a Barack
Obama's speech Mike I felt this girl
growing up my leg I love all the honors
that have come your way all the
publicity who does it make you think of
is there a is there a loved one he's got
so many pluses isn't he own sense he's
personable he's handsome I don't think
we've ever had a president
rincon who is as great a speech writer
as
everything about this first family is
historic you better man in me sir you
really care about us and the American I
could watch that all night long we had
so many Clips by the way we couldn't
even fit them in the the angle okay so
maybe we'll do a special show just to
review all the fawning over Obama but
look the adulation was piled on so high
it was so over-the-top that even Obama
joked and saying about it can somebody
tell me what happened to the Greek
columns that I requested to name my
greatest strength I guess it would be my
humility greatest weakness it's possible
that I am a little too awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
and although Obama left the White House
his cult members haven't left the
commune Democrats are desperate to have
him hit the campaign trails again for
the midterms meet the midterms meets
President Obama yep former President
Obama is waiting into the velvet sea of
this year's midterm elections the Obama
says Democrats should talk about kitchen
table issues you went to the former
President Obama saying we need you
involved in these midterms true I did
about six months ago he and asked for
help and he was gracious and he's
helping us raise some money do they have
no one else to turn to no one I thought
they had such a deep bench in the
Democrat Party don't think for a second
that trumps economic nationalism his
conservative more populist philosophy
won't outlast his presidency it surely
will there's simply no broad
constituency for the old Bush
republicanism of unaccountable trade
deals lacks borders and perpetual
military intervention ISM those days my
friends are over so let the good times
roll until the Democrats and the bitter
bushes come up with some other lame line
of attack against this successful
president and his hopeful very
optimistic supporters and that's the
angle